I feel like you could be able to see it
in my face and I love what I'm doing
right now it's enjoying my life that was
in 2017 but Selena Gomez is still
glowing by the looks of it 26 year old
was snapped looking as happy and chic as
ever on Sunday after church she's
rocking those Capri black overalls with
a white tee underneath and we're loving
the Sonny's and backwards baseball caps
it's hard not to notice the similarity
to this iconic Jen Aniston pic though on
the set of her 1997 movie
picture-perfect hi Selena sweet thing
both ladies pull off the look perfectly
plus we know they're pals Selena Gomez
adorable speaking of adorable take a
look at this video cell also made on
Sunday yeah that's her hit from nearly a
decade ago a year without rain
[Music]
selena has kept a pretty low profile
recently though she stunned on the
carpet at can last week
[Applause]
she was there promoting her new movie
the dead don't die flesh-eating zombies
don't joke it's really really creepy I'm
obsessed with zombies for sure